[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute netz
barbara
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann wunder
von mir und das sind die wichtigsten
themen von heute
neuausrichtung der nato die ostflanke
wird drastisch verstärkt schweden und
finnland werden neue mitglieder
verbrenner aus mit hintertür die eu
staaten beschließen das ende von benzin-
und dieselautos lassen synthetischen
kraftstoffen aber eine schuss- und
dürre notstand in norditalien die
poebene trocknet aus mit verheerenden
folgen für die landwirtschaft
[Musik]
wir müssen auf alles vorbereitet sein
vor allem aus russland das ist tenor auf
dem nato-gipfel die militärallianz müsse
mit der größten krise seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg fertig werden sagt
generalsekretärs deutenberg und spricht
von einem historischen treffen auch
wegen der erweiterung die türkei stimmte
überraschend doch der aufnahme von
schweden und finnland zu
mit schweden und finnland verschiebt
sich die nato aussen grenze deutlich
weiter nach osten die grenzlinie
zwischen finnland und russland ist 1300
kilometer lang nach der offiziellen
aufnahme hätte die nato dann 32
mitgliedsländer aus madrid florian a
er hätte diesen gipfel auch scheitern
lassen können doch schon bevor der
türkische präsident erdogan heute seinen
platz im sitzungssaal sucht hat er
seinem veto gegen den nato beitritt
schwedens und finnlands zurückgezogen
zufrieden mit zusicherungen der beiden
etwa dass die bisher geltende
beschränkungen für waffenlieferungen in
die türkei aufheben und so können sich
die nato spitzen heute um anderes
kümmern ihre neue strategie
unser neues konzept macht klar dass
russland die bedeutendste und direkteste
bedrohung für unsere sicherheit ist im
bisherigen konzept galt russland noch
als strategische partner
vom partner zur bedrohung worauf die
nato mit einer historischen aufrüstung
reagiert die schnelle eingreiftruppe
soll von derzeit 40.000 auf 300.000
soldaten fast verachtfacht werden
deutschland wird eine eigene brigade
über 1000 soldaten bereit halten die
schnell nach litauen verlegt werden
können andere nato staaten soll in
diesem deutschen modell folgen
wir werden unsere zusammenarbeit auch
verbessern indem wir die staaten im
östlichen bereich der nato besser
schützen mit einer besseren
zusammenarbeit und mit mehr truppen was
folgt sind weitere versprechen dass des
us-präsidenten die 100.000 us soldaten
in europa weiter zu verstärken und das
der nato an den ukrainischen präsidenten
sein land weiter mit waffen zu
unterstützen
kann sich auf uns verlassen so lange wie
nötig
die nato richtet sich in madrid neu aus
stellt die weichen auf erweiterungen
richtung norden und auf abschreckung
richtung osten
m at wissen beobachtet für uns den
gipfel in madrid immer auch die
amerikaner verstärkten ihre präsenz in
europa was heißt das
ja die usa verstärken ihre präsenz
stationieren zusätzliche kriegsschiffe
in spanien f 35 kampfjets in
großbritannien neue flugabwehrsysteme in
deutschland und in italien und es
entsteht eine dauerhafte us militärbasis
in polen joe biden war auch direkt
beteiligt offenbar an der einigung in
sachen finnland und schweden die ja dann
künftig die ostflanke stärken können er
hat sich gestern mit erdogan auch
unterhalten war auch an den gesprächen
mittelbar beteiligt angeblich ohne
weitere zugeständnisse an die türkei
aber wir hören aus us regierungskreisen
dass die modernisierung von f 16
kampfjets für die türkei tatsächlich auf
dem weg ist und all das tun die usa und
ihre verbündeten wohl vor allen dingen
um russland abzuschrecken den krieg in
der ukraine auf andere gebiete
auszudehnen
ganz kurz noch nicht nur russland wird
als bedrohung genannt sondern erstmals
auch china was fürchtet die nato
china unterlaufe zusammen mit russland
die rechte basierte weltordnung das ist
der vorwurf und deshalb will man auch
gegen china gegenhalten man hat sich
heute hier getroffen mit pazifik staaten
darunter eben japan südkorea australien
und neuseeland und das ist ein ganz
klares signal dass die nato sich auch
vernetzen will mit pazifik staaten um
dem autoritarismus auch dort in dieser
region die stirn zu bieten
live vom nato-gipfel aus madrid m at
wissen dankeschön
die neue nato strategie ist auch thema
bei heute live mit eindrücken vom gipfel
in madrid und aus kiew dazu
einschätzungen von ex nato general egon
ramms um 19.30 in der zdf- heute auf
youtube und facebook
zumindest eine gute nachricht gibt es
aus der ukraine beim bislang größten
gefangenenaustausch mit russland sind
144 ukrainische soldaten frei gekommen
darunter offenbar kämpfer aus dem
stahlwerk in mario pohl russlands
präsident putin will im energiebereich
stärker mit staaten wie turkmenistan
kasachstan und aserbaidschan
zusammenarbeiten als reaktion auf die
westlichen sanktionen bei seiner ersten
auslandsreise nach dem angriff auf die
ukraine sprach er auch mit vertretern
aus iran
die eu arbeitet weiter daran ihr
klimaschutzpaket umzusetzen in der nacht
verständigten sich die energie und
umweltminister auf verschiedene
maßnahmen ein punkt ist dass aus
verbrenner motoren ab 2035 sollen keine
neuwagen mit diesel oder benzinmotor
mehr zugelassen werden dürfen
ausgenommen sind synthetische
kraftstoffe sogenannten spam team hat
mehr
ob benzin oder diesel der klassische
verbrennungsmotor soll zum auslaufmodell
werden keine neuzulassungen mehr ab 2035
das ist ein großartiger fortschritt für
klimaneutralität im verkehr und ist
dringend notwendig wir haben im verkehr
viel zu tun das wird uns hier
voranbringen und den umstieg auf die
elektromobilität vorantreiben der
verbrenner am ende nicht ganz die fdp
setzt einen prüfauftrag durch mit
sogenannten i fuels also mit künstlich
hergestelltem emissionsfreien sprit soll
auch der verbrennungsmotor eine option
bleiben noch steckt diese technologie
allerdings in den kinderschuhen
verbraucherschützer und umweltverbände
kritisieren damit verwirren man nur
kunden und produzenten und ist ein
prüfauftrag der aus meiner sicht
komplett an der realität auto der großen
automobilhersteller
vorbeigeht die haben sich bereits auf
die voll elektrischen autos eingestellt
die automobilwirtschaft fordert
tatsächlich mehr klarheit darüber wie
ernst es denn nun sei mit den us- viel
größer aber wäre ein anderes problem für
das erklärte eu ziel den fast kompletten
umstieg auf elektromobilität fehle es an
konzepten und ganz praktisch an
ladesäulen
die wirtschaft kann und wird die autos
bauen wir verpflichten uns zu
erheblichen investitionen in
elektromobilität mir macht aber sorge
dass die ladeinfrastruktur in
deutschland in europa nicht in
ausreichendem maße mit gebaut wird hier
wird viel zu wenig aus der sicht der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher gedacht
der verkehrsminister hat gerade heute
einen so genannten ladeinfrastruktur
gipfel veranstaltet will jetzt vor allem
die kommunen stärker einbinden einfach
laden man arbeite daran es ist noch viel
arbeit nötig
7,6 prozent dass es den neuesten
inflationszahlen für juni 0,3 punkte
weniger als noch im mai tank rabatt und
neun euro ticket wirken offenbar wie
eine bremse auf die allgemeine teuerung
preistreiber bleiben aber energie und
lebensmittel ein schnelles ende der
hohen inflation sei nicht in sicht so
ökonomen
besonders trifft die inflation menschen
mit wenig einkommen ihr anteil stieg
auch durch die korona pandemie auf einen
neuen höchststand das zeigen
berechnungen des paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverbands demnach hatten im
vergangenen jahr in deutschland knapp 14
millionen menschen kein sicheres
auskommen das sind mehr als 16 prozent
überdurchschnittlich von armut betroffen
sind nordrhein westfalen thüringen
sachsen anhalt berlin und bremen
ein besonderer ein wichtiger tag für
frankreich fast sieben jahre nach den
terroranschlägen in paris geht heute der
prozess zu ende am 13 november
2015 ermordeten islamistische
terroristen zeitgleich an verschiedenen
orten in paris 130 menschen hunderte
wurden verletzt am platz vor dem start
des fonds in gutbesuchten bars und
restaurants im osten der stadt und im
konzertsaal papa klum susanna santina
berichtet
olivier libaux hat den terror vor fast
sieben jahren im bug lang überlebt er
musste miterleben wie die es terroristen
wahllos dutzende menschen erschossen
das wichtigste für uns ist dass es
diesen prozess überhaupt gibt es ist die
antwort eines rechtsstaates auf einen
barbarischen akt ritter dorf
großes polizeiaufgebot und der
justizpalast weiträumig abgesperrt hier
fällt noch heute das urteil gegen den
einzigen überlebenden des
terrorkommandos saal ab der islam die
anklage fordert für ihn lebenslange haft
ohne option vorher frei zu kommen 13
weitere angeklagte stehen unter anderem
wegen mittäterschaft vor gericht
dreizehnter november 2015 erst
terroristen erschießen 130 menschen
hunderte werden verletzt das konzert in
bad orb 20 minuten als die terroristen
auch hier wahllos um sich schießend
konzertbesucher versuchen sich in
todesangst zu retten
der schock sitzt bei allen tief wir sind
abgehauen aber wir waren 15
am ende hat uns die polizei heraus
geführt das war ein einziges
schlachtfeld ein massaker
1800 nebenkläger gab es in diesem
prozess darunter auch viele opfer
nie aus dem gefängnis raus kommen wir
hoffen sehr dass das gericht so
entscheidet
im prozess hatte sich unter anderem
salopp des lamm bei den opfern
entschuldigt für olivier libaux ist das
nichts wert
sie haben einfach die gelegenheit
genutzt sich reumütig zu zeigen damit
sie eine mildere strafe bekommen
es sei heute für sie alle ein sehr
emotionaler und wichtiger tag
in kiel ist der alte ministerpräsident
auch der neue rund sieben wochen nach
der landtagswahl wurde daniel günther
wiedergewählt und zwar mit deutlicher
mehrheit
die schwarz grüne landesregierung will
schleswig holstein bis 2040 klimaneutral
machen von den acht ministerien
übernimmt die cdu fünf die grünen drei
endlose schlangen vor dem check-in
massive verspätungen gestrichene flüge
wer aktuell zum start der sommerferien
eine flugreise gebucht hat braucht
starke nerven
die regierung kritisiert die
luftfahrtbranche dafür und will ihr
jetzt ermöglichen hilfskräfte aus dem
ausland zur unterstützung zu holen
markus wolsiffer hat die details
reisende müssen in diesen tagen vor
allem geduld mitbringen etwa in
düsseldorf wo zuletzt 1000 gepäckstücke
zurückblieben und viele frustrierte
urlauber damit so etwas nicht wieder
passiert soll nun beschäftigte aus dem
ausland mit anpacken wir helfen
pragmatisch arbeitskräfte herzuholen
aber mir ist wichtig und uns dass jede
form von sozialdumping und ausbeutung
ausgeschlossen würden und das heißt
zuvorderst wir werden keine leiharbeit
zulassen die firmen werden die
arbeitskräfte direkt an stellen müssen
helfen werden wohl einige tausend vor
allem aus der türkei sie sollen bei der
bodenabfertigung und beim gepäck
eingesetzt werden ihre nötigen
aufenthalts und arbeitserlaubnisse will
die bundesregierung rasch erteilen es
müsse aber sichergestellt sein dass die
arbeitskräfte menschenwürdig
untergebracht werden außerdem müssen sie
die regulären strengen sicherheits
überprüfungen durchlaufen doch die
kosten zeit meist mehrere wochen
experten warnen deshalb vor zu hohen
erwartungen
mitarbeiter aus dem ausland zu holen ist
eine maßnahme von vielen die einen
begrenzten effekt haben werden die sich
vielleicht dann in der zweiten
jahreshälfte bruder im dritten oder im
vierten quartal auswirken werden aber
sicherlich kaum während der sommerferien
saison die regierung kritisiert
flughäfen und airlines für das chaos sie
hätten mehr personal eingespart als
nötig obwohl sie mit milliarden in der
pandemie unterstützt wurden gerade um
die jobs zu sichern
es wäre aufgabe der unternehmen gewesen
dazu rechtzeitig vorsorge zu treffen wir
müssen feststellen dass es nicht in
ausreichendem maße gelungen die branche
müsse insgesamt daran arbeiten wieder
attraktiver zu werden dazu gehören
höhere löhne und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen für das personal am
flughafen
der frühere vorsitzende der fdp martin
bangemann ist tot der starb im alter von
87 jahren als leidenschaftlichen
liberalen und streiter für die
marktwirtschaft würde ich der fdp chef
lindner den ehemaligen
bundeswirtschaftsminister und eu
industriekommissar bangemann war von
1985 bis 88 vorsitzender der fdp
schwere unwetter mit überschwemmungen
und schlammlawinen haben das bundesland
kärnten in österreich hart getroffen
mindestens ein mensch starb ein weiterer
wird noch vermisst einige häuser sind
bis zum ersten stock verschüttet die
behörden riefen in zwei orten die
menschen dazu auf sich im ersten stock
ihrer häuser in sicherheit zu bringen
da im freien lebensgefahr herrsche
komplett anderes bild in italien viel zu
wenig bis gar kein regen verbunden mit
hitze schon früh im jahr das ist seit
monaten die situation im norden des
landes besonders betroffen sind die
großen regionen der poebene der fluss
selbst führt so wenig wasser wie seit 70
jahren nicht mehr vor allem die die für
die landwirtschaft ist die dürre schon
jetzt verheerend annette hilsenbeck war
vor ort
der reis den landwirt die suscon solar
angepflanzt hat es kaum mehr zu retten
gelbe spitzen die blätter
zusammengerollt er hat keine hoffnung
dass das noch was wird
die wurzeln müssten mehr entwickelt sein
sie sind sehr oberflächlich und haben
keine chance irgendwo feuchtigkeit zu
finden diese pflanze wird nichts
produzieren weinprobe
70 prozent der geplanten ernte wird er
wohl verlieren weil es nicht genug
wasser gibt hier in der reiskammer
italiens wo über die hälfte der
europäischen reisernte produziert wird
hat es seit januar kaum geregnet und die
bewässerung ist stark eingeschränkt der
fluss po der das piemont und die
lombardei mit wasser versorgt ist zu
einem rinnsal verkümmert nicht nur reis
auch mais oder gemüse verdorren auf den
feldern wegen wassermangels hat die
stadt mailand fontänen abgestellt in
mehr als 300 gemeinden im norden
italiens gilt inzwischen wassernotstand
dort kommt vielerorts nachts kein wasser
aus der leitung um das wasser desaster
zu mindern soll nun aus dem gardasee dem
größten wasserspeicher norditalien viel
mehr wasser als sonst in den po
abgeleitet werden di garda gemeinden
wehren sich weil auch der pegel des sees
rapide sinkt
anstatt einen kranken zu haben werden
wir zwei haben nämlich po und gardasee
der gardasee steckt auch in
schwierigkeiten denn wir kriegen uns im
vorrat normalerweise im winter zum
mangel an schnee kam da noch der mangel
an regen dazu es ist ein kampf ums
wasser und der könnte noch schärfer
werden jetzt wo die heißen sommermonate
beginnen
eine ausführliche reportage dazu gibt es
im auslandsjournal um viertel nach zehn
und jetzt zur schwimm em in budapest
norbert auch heute wieder mit deutschen
medaillen jain freiwasser wettbewerben
florian wellbrock der hatte ja schon
zweimal gold im super g geholt heute kam
bronze über die zehn kilometer dazu ja
und leonie beck die hat über dieselbe
distanz ihre zweite goldmedaille nur
haarscharf verpasst der krimi der leonie
beck hier in der mitte eines trios
längst hat die 25 jährige würzburgerin
als staffel-weltmeisterin gezeigt dass
sie eine größe im freiwasser ist
verpasst in einem packenden finish
hinter der niederländerin van daal nach
über zwei stunden über zehn kilometern
um fünf zehntel ihr zweites gold diese
anzahl hat florian wellbrock hier hinten
liegend schon gewonnen will ein
historisches gold-triple aber diesmal
wird olympiasieger wellbrock hinter zwei
italienern dritter mit dem sieger
gregory kathrin i schöne statistik für
wellbrock durch seine fünfte medaille
hatte genauso viele wm medaille bei
einer wm gewonnen wie einst die
schwimmlegende michael groß vor 40
jahren
zum tennisturnier in wimbledon hat
angelique kerber souverän die dritte
runde erreicht und für eine faustdicke
überraschung sagte die 22 jährige
dortmunderin juli niemeyer sie spielt
zum ersten mal gegen eine
top-ten-spielerin doch die erste
internet kontakt weltranglistendritte
und den wimmelten an nummer zwei gesetzt
macht zu viele fehler während julia
niemeyer jeden break-ball gewinnt gute
returns spielt um mit offensivspiel
glänzt nach 58 minuten ist das
unglaubliche match mit 6 4 und 6 0
gewonnen
ein besonderes gefühl gerade hier auch
in wimbledon bei einem sehr besonderen
turnier mein größte sieg in meiner
karriere zu wollen zum ersten mal steht
sie hier in der dritten runde gegnerin
ist lesja zurenko aus der ukraine
den ersten schwarz-gelben schweiß in der
neuen saison den gab es heute in
dortmund trainingsauftakt beim bvb noch
ohne die nationalspieler und neuzugänge
wie adeyemi schlotterbeck oder alle
dafür mit dem neuen groß ihr trainer
edin terzic der wie er selbst sagt in
der neuen saison feiern will die noch
nie
die fans wollen natürlich auch mitfeiern
55.000 dauerkarten wurden wieder
verkauft bundesliga spitze sind einfach
treue seele nun allerdings fehlt noch
das lotto die gewinnzahlen lauten 21 22
24 40
45 48 und die superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf.de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
morgen startet der tag meist sonnig nur
im osten anfangs noch schauer und
gewitter mehr dazu gleich von christa
orden das heute journal um viertel vor
zehn mit marietta slomka wir seinen
chips und wünschen ihnen noch einen sehr
schönen abends bis morgen wenn sie
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend herr jetzt am wochenende
machen die gewitter mal pause bis zum
freitag sind die aber noch unterwegs und
heute nacht verschiebt sich die gefahr
von lokalem starkregen aus dem südosten
in den äußersten osten des landes in der
feuchten luft dahinter gibt sie und da
mal ein paar nebelfelder im westen ist
die nacht meist klar dazu sinken die
temperaturen auf 18 grad in der gewitter
luft und 12 grad am alpenrand
morgen gehts dann verbreitet auf um die
30 grad wieder hinauf nur in den höheren
lagen an den alpen und im nordosten ist
es mit 22 bis 25 grad kühler hier liegt
nämlich noch die wolkige luft aus der
nacht mit schauern und einzelnen
gewittern sonst startet der tag sonnig
am nachmittag da ziehen zum einen die
schauer und gewitter nach nordosten ab
es gibt einzelne gewitter über den
mittelgebirgen zwischen dem niederrhein
und den alpen da kommen aber neue
schauer und gewitter auf da dann auch
lokal starkregen und sturmböen möglich
das ganze gehört nämlich zu einer
kaltfront und die überquert in der nacht
auf freitag das ganze land kommt in etwa
bis zur elbe voran bringt dann am
freitag selbst im osten mal etwas regen
dahinter kühlt es ab am samstag und am
sonntag ist es aber schon wieder trocken
und es gibt ein sommerwochenende mit bis
31 grad